i've got that wand lust
i'm gonna walk the scene we will get
back to this buddy at the end of the
video um but before that i want to tell
you about the summer of math exposition
number two so last year we did the
summer of math exposition number one
which was essentially an open invitation
for people to make explanatory math
content that they might have thought
about making before but just get an
excuse for us to all do it at the same
time and together and the way we did it
is we framed it as a contest so we had
different participants a lot of them
were videos not all of them were videos
we had a process for selecting winners
and aside from the competition aspect of
it which is really just an excuse to
have a deadline and have that little
extra push to try to make something as
good as you can the most exciting part
was just how many really solid pieces of
content came out of that in fact i was
curious the other day and i went to look
at the analytics and just looking at the
video content mainly because that's
where it's easiest to count the total
number of hits on it of all of the video
submissions to the first summer of math
exposition if we count up all the views
that they accumulated it's over 15
million total views there so we want to
do it again
if you have some kind of math explainer
that you've been thinking about making
and posting online in some capacity
whatever that is and if you want to use
this summer as an excuse to make it
happen there are really just three main
bits of logistics number one subscribe
to the official mailing list that we're
going to use for it all of the official
communication about things like
timelines rules for submissions answers
to any questions that people might have
had all of it's gonna live there
secondly the submission deadline is
august 15th so try to finish whatever
you're making maybe five days before
that because we have to be immovable
with some kind of line and august 15th
is going to be that line and then if you
want to engage with other people who are
also participating in the event maybe
share some of your work or get some
feedback or just chat about math in
general
there's a discord for it and last year
the discord was really the lifeblood of
the whole event i mean we had the
announcement we had the choosing of the
winners but all of the real community
components of it happened on that
discord in between
but with this year i also wanted to add
one tiny little twist to the whole event
so i've always thought it might be nice
to somehow play matchmaker between
domain experts people like
mathematicians or professors of other
kinds or teachers or professionals the
people who have the know-how and the
experience with respect to some
technical topic they know the best
stories to tell but maybe they don't
have the time to actually put together a
video or they don't have the you know
video making skills and content creation
skills and then pair them together with
content producers whether that's people
who are really interested in making
videos video editing animation or maybe
web developers interested in interactive
blog posts game developers artists
whatever the form of content creation
might be because if you limit your scope
to the world of online educational
content creation by individuals you have
to live in this little intersection here
between the people who have good lessons
to teach and then the people who have
the time and the interest and then the
technical know-how to put together that
content but with well-organized
collaboration you can get a lot of good
content out of the union of those two
sets rather than just the intersection
and i think a shining example of this
would be the entire channel number file
where you've got brady who's a very
talented journalist and interviewer and
film creator videographer and he goes
and interviews the various experts out
there and a lot of the experts wouldn't
be making their own videos but by
pairing together with brady they get a
really polished and well thought out
product from it all another interesting
example of a collaboration like this one
is uh let me see what was it called how
to construct a leech lattice it's on the
channel for richard borchertz who's a
fields medalist mathematician who makes
a lot of his own videos just kind of
overhead shot lectures but this one was
a partnership with someone who went in
and took one of those lectures but added
some animations and visuals on top to
really help clarify what was being said
because the whole thing is about
lattices in 24 dimensions which is hard
to picture
it's a very pleasing construction of
them which is both described and
illustrated very beautifully
and to incentivize more collaborations
like that one we've put together a
simple space to help people find
collaborators more on that in a moment
and then at least one of the winners
that we choose this year will be from
the set of people who've found a
collaborator in this way and also i will
throw my hat into this bunch and try to
partner with some of the people in that
space to maybe make a three blue and
brown video
so the way this will work uh might look
a little bit weird at first but bear
with me we've set up a github repo and
we're going to use github issues on that
repository as a way of organizing
requests for collaboration so let's say
you're a mathematician you have some
idea for a good piece of expository
content maybe it's a video you think
should get made or an interactive blog
post but you want to find someone to
help you actually carry it out
you would go and create a new issue you
would use the template for a topic
seeking a producer
and then you just fill it out with all
the details of your idea and the more
details the better you know let's say i
was going to partner with some
mathematician to produce something i
would be interested in seeing you know
pretty good outline of the idea why it's
important maybe even a storyboard in
there
and then on the flip side if you want to
produce some kind of content you know
you're an artist or an animator or a
video creator but you're more interested
in getting content ideas from the
experts than from yourself you would
also create an issue
use the producer seeking topic template
and then fill that out so then if you're
looking for a collaborator so let's say
i'm going there i'm looking for
mathematicians with interesting ideas or
artists and animators that i might want
to work with you can take a look at all
of the open issues and the reason for
using github for this even though that
might feel a little bit weird is that
the tools seem right for what we want in
terms of having a dedicated conversation
for each thread having nice math
embedding in each one of them making it
easy to link between them and once
you've found your collaborator and
you're no longer looking for one you can
close the issue if that's a totally wild
way to do it feel free to complain at me
but for my part at least over the next
week or two i'll be in there i'll take a
look through what the requests for
collaboration are i think it would be
fun for me at least to find some domain
expert with an interesting topic that i
wouldn't have known to produce and then
i was thinking of also finding someone
who's interested in content creation
seems like they have at least a little
bit of a portfolio such that i can tell
if the style would mesh well with
whatever topic from the domain expert i
end up finding and then i would be there
as a kind of producer and extra
collaborator and we could post the final
product on three blue on brown
and so that's the added twist but other
than that same deal as last year again
this time we'll choose at least five
different winners and again brilliant
has generously offered to contribute
five thousand dollars for prizes to the
winners so we'll give a thousand dollars
to each one also this year slightly
different twist uh each winner will be
sent a golden pie creature of which only
five exist in the whole world so if
that's not enough to get you to
contribute i don't know what will other
than that again all of the official
details are in the email list take a
look at that first post to get all the
details that i probably forgot to
mention in this video and honestly i'm
really excited to see what people make
[Music]
you